hello everyone and welcome to the game
we said that we were gonna show
it's another game where the evans gambit
was employed for the first time also
between william davies evans the
inventor of the evans gambit and
alexander mcdonnell
uh and uh well uh we'll just uh show you
and then you can decide
which one was placed played first and
which one do you enjoy more and before
we check out the game
uh if you guys want to see something
really weird uh click on the first link
in the description below it's really
really weird like if you ever wanted to
hear me sing but not really hear me sing
uh you know do check it out it's it's
quite weird i don't know so some people
like it i like it
so maybe you guys will will like it uh
that being said uh
let's check out the game uh william
davies evans again goes for e4 and
this is the same like uh that one was
played in nine uh 1829 la
london this one's at 1825 so some three
to four years uh
prior to that game with e5 knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 again we
have the joko piano bishop the c5
and now not b4 but actually here uh
evans castles and it's weird to say that
the first time the evans gamble was
employed
the evans gambit wasn't even played but
we will
very quickly transpose into the evans
gambit so it's
like like it was so d6 by mcdonald we
have b
for now uh capture sun b for nc3 with
bishop to a5 and
now d4 uh we've uh and now basically
we've reached the evans gambit where
it's the same like b4 was played right
away c3 bishop to a5 and then
black at some point closed with d6 so
the evans gambit now is officially on
the board
uh bishop to g4 by mcdonnell and now
queen to b3 and this is some very
standard
evan's gambit stuff you're attacking f7
you're putting pressure on b7
and black has a bishop on a5 so you
don't have knight to a5
for with an attack on the bishop and the
queen so black needs to deal with this
uh usually you can even uh throw in an
in-between bishop captures on f3
which is uh which is known today then if
captures king f8 is perfectly fine
uh but in those days queen to d7 just
guarding the f7 pawn
and now knight the g5 so now you have a
triple attack on the f7 pawn
and the way you want to defend this is
by knight to h6 defending the f7 pawn
however
mcdonald played knight to d8 and here's
a problem now the knight is guarding f7
but no longer guards
e5 and now uh there are a couple of ways
you can take advantage of this
uh with d captures on e5 so d captures
on e5 we have d
captures on e5 and now uh if uh well
this is one of those cases where again
whether you
are an artist or or a butcher uh it
depends on what you will do
uh so here bishop captures an f7 is uh
very winning for white for example
knight captures knight captures queen
captures
and now you capture on b7 win upon
attack the rook and once the rook
is saved the only then you go queen b5
check win back your piece
and now you're just enjoying your extra
pawn
and a better position as the king is
still in the center of the board black
still needs to develop and you are doing
just fine
however here evans wants to keep the
pressure he plays bishop to a3 another
uh pretty much uh signature evans
move as it prevents the the king from
castling and also the bishop
strikes this way so the bishop player is
now fully operational
and only now knight stage six here this
is a move that really does nothing
because your
f7 pawn is protected you don't need to
defend it again
so better would be something to just
maybe play bishop to
bishop to h5 to to add protection to it
this way or maybe
c6 for the queen to guard b7 and then
try to develop somehow however here
knight to h6 was played and now there's
a problem here
evans finds a very interesting idea
first he plays f3
takes away the bishop's defense of the
d1 square he wants to play rook to b1
to get the queen away because the queen
doesn't really have all that many
squares to guard the f7 square from and
this is probably why mcdonald played
the knight to h6 so asked to add another
defender because here
all of these squares as you can see are
taken the queen will not be able to stay
there
so first bishop to b6 with check this
way you also block the
the queens attacked at a b7 pawn king to
h1 and now
bishop to h5 finally getting that bishop
out of harm's way
uh but now there's a problem and uh well
since we already mentioned what the
problem is i'm not going to ask you to
pause the video here but
we will have a pause a video moment so
don't worry about that
uh rook to d1 takes advantage of the
queen being here the queen needs to move
as we said
none of these squares are available so
queen goes here of course if you
try something like queen here then
immediately just this wins the queen
not a problem so queen to c8 and now
comes uh
well again you could do a lot of things
here
for example queen b5 check wins on the
spot as you also connect with the e5
pawn and
the black king doesn't really have all
that many squares but evans tried
something else
uh and here for example if c6 then you
can capture here and then just
everything gets traded off and you just
win easily captures captures and
captures you attack the queen queen has
to move
and now check king here and bishop e8 is
a nice evergreen checkmate
if you don't know why it's an evergreen
checkmate you should check out the
evergreen game game i will also put a
link to that game in the description
below as it's uh well
one of the nicest games ever so what you
would have to do after queen b5 check
which was not played in the game
is knight the c6 add a defender here to
the e5 pawn
but now you have uh less defenders of
the f7 pawn and bishop to d5
is just uh well uh
you know certain doom is inevitable
because here after you defend it
let's say captures and captures now
comes again queen captures an e5 you
easily remove the defender of the e5
pawn and now everything is the same the
king has no squares you have to block
with the queen because here
everything is taken away from the black
king queen has to block and now it's
just
captures captures and the queen captures
an e6 with checkmate
so that being said after this queen to
see it uh
queen to b5 check wins however we have
rook captures on d8
evans evans plays in the greatest of
styles he removes the defender of the f7
pawn
uh we have queen captures and now knight
captures on f7 putting pressure on the
queen uh inviting knight characters here
but if knight captures then again
not this because the bishop covers that
but now it's bishop to b5 check
c6 and again queen to e6 check followed
by queen e7 and queen captures with
checkmate so yeah you cannot do this
after knight captures on f7
mcdonald played queen to h4 queen to f6
is the way to go with queen to f6 the
game actually continues
with white of course being better but
it's essential for the queen to come to
f6 to guard the e6 square but here
mcdonnell played queen to h4
and now uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find
same as in the previous video it's
checkmate in three so
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
mate evans missed and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to b5 check queen to b5 check
uh is mate in three but uh sorry bishop
to b5 check is maintaining three but
evans went for queen to b5 check which
is made in four but we are going to show
them eighteen three that you all found
uh because now it's bishop b5 check you
clear the queen's path to the e6 square
of course this needs to be blocked this
is the only move
queen e6 checked and now there are no
more squares this is covered by the
bishop discovered by the knight so the
queen has to block and this is now
checkmate so this would be made in three
but mate in three or mating for doesn't
really matter all that much uh queen to
b5 check was played
now just connecting with with the e5
pawn sd5 pawn is undefended here
so uh here we have c6 blocking and now
queen captures on e5 with
check king to d7 was played we have
queen to e6 check
king to c7 and of course now finishing
the game with bishop to d6 checkmate
so really really uh amazing attack
amazing checkmate uh good defensive
moves by mcdonnell
at some point he could have chosen you
know some some better moves but all in
all he didn't play
all that terrible uh i've you know i
faced uh
worse opponents playing the evans gambit
online and
i don't know i decided to show you these
two games well we should we've shown the
game that leela now played against
stockwish with that brilliant uh
knights the e5 sacrifice followed by
that positional rook a to e1
then we've shown the first ever game
where the evans gambit was played and
then now we've shown the first ever game
where the evans gambit was
actually played or not you know
depending on on how you view things
and i don't know i thought you guys will
enjoy it uh we we do mention events game
but quite a lot but i thought
if you see you know what what can happen
if you if you play
it well if your opponent makes only
slight inaccuracies then maybe
you know uh people will start playing it
more often at least in bulletin blitz
i'm not expecting anyone to play it in
classical
uh but in blitz and bullet you know uh
why not uh so yeah
that's the game i do hope you enjoyed it
uh these are the only two games between
william davies sevens and alexander
mcdonnell both of them
uh were the evans gambit one the
immediate one one a postponed one that
transitioned into the the evans gambit
so i do hope you enjoyed both of them
and like i said do check out the links
in the description below
one really weird stuff and the second
one the evergreen game if you haven't
seen it it's an old video i know in
only 30 frames per second but it's the
movies that that count
uh so yeah once again i hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank
asa finkelstein uh tarian asset uh taren
is
carson webber uh uh cameron alice
enterprises and james slaughter for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the good
stuff finally checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day